alright what's up this is my friend a
day and today we're gonna be swapping
barbers I'm petrified I don't know if
this guy knows how to work with black
hair like texture hairstyles doesn't
even know black people and they told me
that his barber is the best barber in
all of New York City number one and I'm
telling him I've had my barber for the
past five years he's never messed up my
hair he's the only guy who's ever given
me a good haircut wait wait this is the
same barber that gave you the little
thing on top of your head
yes it was the same car with a chameleon
button but I asked him for a man bun and
it was a pretty good man button when you
think about it like and this is the
barber but that gave me this I get here
cuts every two to three weeks so we're
in the second week right now I wait till
it like gets really jew-fro like till my
Jew fro gets like so Jew fro that I have
to cut it I've almost never gotten a
good haircut until I met my current
barber and I've never gone to anybody
else I've never cheated on my barber
ever ever ever every time I come in he
says have you been working out he's like
oh my god you look bigger and I'm like
no honestly a days in for a great
experience my barber is the nicest man
I've ever met he's gonna bring up a day
he's gonna wash his hair give him a
little massage give him a nice little
trim make him look fresh let him go
wouldn't they walk in me he's either
gonna hear some like gangster rap he's
gonna hear trap or he's gonna hear some
like salsa I think this is gonna be the
new and improved Eric he's gonna be like
the R&B Eric he's gonna be like the
SoundCloud rapper Eric this is gonna be
something you've never seen before if my
haircut ends up looking anything like a
days hair I might cry how much does your
barber cost it's a 25 to 30 dollars
yeah same is mine so we have basically
the same price line and we're gonna see
whose barbers better so let's let's
let's swap barbers
all right what's up we're at Rafael's
barbershop my barbershop and eggs about
to get a nice haircut
facial shaping he's about to be kids my
barber so let's go up all right how you
will the fact that I see this and I see
somebody that looks similar like safe
head of hair stylist me I feel a lot
more comfortable all right let's go
let's go
so you gonna burn me but in the end this
is the best place in the world
where's kick kick here kids is here good
[Music]
so this is who you're gonna be getting a
haircut what's your plan how are you
gonna tackle this how do you feel about
me getting a haircut from his barber oh
oh yeah
surprise you're not gonna man no but I
know
let's go give a day the best haircut of
his life okay so while a day gets this
haircut we're gonna turn him away from
the mirror so he has no idea what his
hair looks like until the very end
have you ever given anybody a bad
haircut where are you from originally
[Music]
ain't looking better already
so you're gonna make my barber hate me
he's never gonna talk to me again
cuz he's gonna see this right after and
he's gonna ask me who cut my hair go to
him he can to mess it up
you remember this hand you gave Erica
man bun yeah let me come back to day
later
am I getting more beautiful how did you
start want to make money so difficult
I don't more quick many time really yeah
many time for heart how long did it take
you to get comfortable Oh full year for
years Wow what did it feel like when you
were first starting and you would give a
bad haircut like how did people react
before I feel bad but afterwards good
people would yell at you
[Music]
[Music]
today's about to get the straight razor
on his face this is for the blood a day
good luck
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh what did you think does your barber
give you experience like that absolutely
not
that was that was amazing that was
intense ready one two three
[Music]
I like good okay you look good
now you look much too okay
honest review where do you think I mean
now that he's not here I felt a little
guilty but I mean he did a good job but
it's not how I'm used to getting this is
serious
beard is going on here how do you think
on the top though no the top does that
was good I think this half it's just
lawyer I think once you get used to your
barber yeah it's hard to switch barbers
cuz it's like a family member they know
you better than anybody else so it's
like really hard to switch partners
that's why I'm nervous
to go to your barber because I just I
feel like he doesn't get me I actually
just set up a picture of one of your
photos on Instagram
he said this him I make better he's like
okay yeah Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is he putting his initials in my air
right finish I'm finished I like it
ooh the back looks nice I think this is
a great experience like trying new
Barbara was fun right learning new
things like I'm down to be more
experimental with my barber and my
haircuts and stuff I realized that a
barber is a place where you can relax
it's not you know like intense getting
it out you just take your time
appreciate and enjoy the haircut each
barber is like super different to my
Barbara took like longer and like did
like massages and stuff Alex was like
bam bam bam exciting and I got a new
name I'm poppy now this is fun you thank
you okay are you ready
good you guys are gonna be best friends
you guys should open up a barbershop
together
[Music]